This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's an archipelago in the far west of the UK. And I mean far west. Like once you think you're in the west, like around Cornwall, keep going. And then take a ferry, another three hours west. And you'll find yourself in a collection of islands called the Isles of Silly. That's silly spelled S-C-I-L-L-Y, not silly, ha-ha.
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。在英国的最西端有一个群岛。我是说真正的最西端。当你觉得你已经到了西边，比如到了康沃尔附近，继续往前走。然后坐上渡轮，再向西航行三个小时。你就会发现自己置身于一个名为锡利群岛（Isles of Scilly）的岛屿群中。锡利（Scilly）的拼写是S-C-I-L-L-Y，不是“傻瓜”（silly）那个词，哈哈。
That's 99-P-I-I-P-I-P-RUcer, Kelly Prime. In fact, silly. is not ha ha at all. It's a place that's hard to wrap your mind around. The islands sit in the warm waters of the Gulf Stream, so you'll find tropical plants like giant palms and birds of paradise, all blooming up against the backdrop of the rugged North Atlantic. It's also historically, one of the deadliest places in the UK to travel by sea. These islands are plopped down in churning waters, with jagged rocks rising all around like the jaws of some sort of mythical sea creature.
那是99-P-I-I-P-I-P-RUcer，凯利·普莱姆。事实上，锡利群岛一点也不“傻”。这是一个让人难以理解的地方。这些岛屿坐落在墨西哥湾暖流的温暖水域中，所以你会发现像巨型棕榈树和天堂鸟这样的热带植物，它们在崎岖的北大西洋背景下竞相绽放。从历史上看，这也是英国海上航行最危险的地方之一。这些岛屿坐落在汹涌的水域中，周围耸立着锯齿状的岩石，就像某种神话海怪的下颚。
In this past October, I found myself on a little boat called the Buccaneer right in the middle of it. It's a crazy, man. It's a crazy place. There's just rocks everywhere. As you're going along, you don't realize we're passing rocks under the water all the time. The Buccaneer belongs to a scuba diver named Todd Stevens. Todd has been diving the shipwrecks around Silly for over two decades. If you're in the shipwrecks, it's really hard not to find one here.
去年十月，我发现自己正坐在一艘名为“海盗号”（Buccaneer）的小船上，就在这片海域的中央。这太疯狂了，伙计。这是一个疯狂的地方。到处都是岩石。当你航行时，你根本没意识到我们一直在经过水下的岩石。“海盗号”属于一位名叫托德·史蒂文斯的潜水员。托德在锡利群岛周围潜水寻找沉船已经超过二十年了。如果你对沉船感兴趣，在这里很难找不到一艘。
At least 900 shipwrecks litter the coasts of Silly, probably more. Sometimes ships will sink on top of other older shipwrecks, so it's difficult to say for sure. Are there shipwrecks below us right now? Yeah, yeah, we'd ask quite a few. If you'd have been asking me that as we were just coming along Samaria shoreline, there's at least half a dozen along there. Oh, my God. Are there life jackets on this boat?
至少有900艘沉船散落在锡利群岛的海岸上，可能更多。有时船只会在更古老的沉船残骸上沉没，所以很难确定具体数字。我们现在下面有沉船吗？有，有，我们问过好几次了。如果你刚才在我们经过萨马里亚海岸线时问我，那里至少有六艘。天哪。这船上有救生衣吗？
We were specifically looking for the remains of one particular disaster. We're not one, but four ships were lost on the same night. The HMS Association, Romney, Eagle and Firebrand. We're just coming up on the firebrand now. So we're right over it now. The wreck lays just across here. And her bowels are up that way because her anchors are up that end. And then she lays across here.
我们当时专门在寻找一场特定灾难的残骸。不是一艘，而是四艘船在同一个晚上失事了。分别是“协会号”（HMS Association）、“罗姆尼号”（Romney）、“鹰号”（Eagle）和“火炬号”（Firebrand）。我们现在正靠近“火炬号”。我们现在就在它正上方。残骸就在这边。它的船尾在那边，因为它的锚在那一头。然后它横跨在这里。
The wrecks happened on October 22, 1707. It was quite literally a dark and stormy night, and there was a fleet of British naval ships bravely led by an admiral named Cloudly Shovel. Shovel and his fleet had just fought a battle with the French. They were headed back and, according to their maps, they were about to pass safely into the English Channel. But in reality, they were actually 200 miles off course, exactly where you really do not want to be.
这些沉船事故发生在1707年10月22日。那是一个名副其实的黑暗风暴之夜，当时有一支由海军上将克劳德利·肖维尔（Cloudly Shovel）勇敢率领的英国海军舰队。肖维尔和他的舰队刚刚与法国人打了一仗。他们正在返航，根据地图，他们本应安全进入英吉利海峡。但实际上，他们偏离了航线200英里，正好处于你最不想去的地方。
Smack in the middle of the Isles of Silly. The HMS Association crashed into one of the many jagged rocks just beneath the surface of the water. The death toll was somewhere between 1,400 and 2,000. It was, at the time, the deadliest shipwreck in British history. But the important thing about this shipwreck, why it's still remembered today, isn't just the scale of the disaster. It's also why it happened and how it could have been avoided.
就在锡利群岛的中央。“协会号”撞上了水面下众多的锯齿状岩石之一。死亡人数在1400到2000人之间。在当时，这是英国历史上最惨重的海难。但关于这次海难，人们至今仍铭记的重要原因，不仅仅是灾难的规模，还在于它发生的原因以及本可以如何避免。
Because the navigators of the fleet were missing a vital piece of information. And do we know why they thought they were that far? Yeah, well, they didn't know the longitude. So they're guessing. The reason this fleet was so dangerously off course was because they didn't know their longitude, their east-west coordinates. And this wasn't because they lost their map or their navigator was killed by pirates, or they were just really bad at their jobs.
因为舰队的领航员缺少了一项至关重要的信息。我们知道他们为什么认为自己在那儿吗？是的，好吧，他们不知道经度。所以他们是在猜。这支舰队之所以如此危险地偏离航线，是因为他们不知道自己的经度，也就是东西坐标。这并不是因为他们弄丢了地图，或者领航员被海盗杀了，又或者他们工作能力真的很差。
They didn't know their longitude because at that point, no one knew how to calculate longitude at sea. It was a problem that it plagued navigators and scientists for centuries. The greatest minds of Europe, Isaac Newton, Galileo Galilei, and the Haley's Comet guy. They all tried and failed to find a way to calculate longitude at sea. Most people thought it simply wasn't possible. That is until the 18th century, when the disaster in Silly helped inspire Britain to action. What follows is a tale of imperial greed, a lucrative contest, and an obsessive underdog who became his own worst enemy. But before we tell you about all that, we need to explain what Longitude actually is, which is a lot harder than it sounds.
他们不知道经度，是因为在那个时候，没人知道如何在海上计算经度。这是一个困扰了航海家和科学家几个世纪的问题。欧洲最伟大的头脑，艾萨克·牛顿、伽利略·伽利莱，还有发现哈雷彗星的那位，他们都尝试过，但都没能找到计算海上经度的方法。大多数人认为这根本不可能。直到18世纪，锡利群岛的灾难促使英国采取了行动。接下来是一个关于帝国贪婪、一场利润丰厚的竞赛，以及一个成为自己最大敌人的痴迷失败者的故事。但在讲述这一切之前，我们需要解释一下什么是经度，这比听起来要难得多。
Basically, longitude is the east-west coordinate. So if you think of the earth as an orange, and you peel 24 vertical pieces of that orange, each peel 15 degrees of longitude away from the prime meridian. And that's because longitude is counted off in the same direction as the earth is rotating on its axis. So, you know, I think I'll start over on this description. It's gotten away from me. This is Alexei Baker, manager of the History of Science and Technology Collection at the Peabody Museum. And see? I told you this was hard. Should I use the orange? Should I not use the orange? Okay.
基本上，经度就是东西坐标。如果你把地球想象成一个橙子，剥下24片垂直的果皮，每一片果皮距离本初子午线15度经度。这是因为经度的计算方向与地球自转的方向相同。所以，你知道，我想重新描述一下。我刚才说乱了。这是皮博迪博物馆科学技术史收藏馆的经理亚历克西·贝克。看？我告诉过你这很难。我该用橙子吗？我不该用橙子吗？好吧。
Maybe let's give it a try without any citrus fruits. So longitude are the vertical lines on the globe and latitude are the horizontal lines. And when you move besides beyond vertical and horizontal lines, it does quickly get away from you. I'm going to try to do this as simply as possible. So latitude and longitude came about when some Greek guy from a very long time ago decided to throw some lines on the globe. The idea being that if we put lines on a map, they'll form a grid, and then people can use that grid to navigate the world with more precision. This grid is what gives us GPS coordinates. For example, the Pandora building in beautiful uptown, Oakland, California.
也许我们不用柑橘类水果试试。经度是地球仪上的垂直线，纬度是水平线。当你移动到垂直线和水平线之外时，它很快就会变得难以理解。我尽量简单地解释。纬度和经度是很久以前某个希腊人决定在地球仪上画几条线时产生的。想法是，如果我们把线画在地图上，它们就会形成一个网格，然后人们就可以利用这个网格更精确地导航世界。这个网格就是我们现在GPS坐标的来源。例如，加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的潘多拉大厦。
That's around 37.810 North, 122.267 south. The trouble with this imaginary grid system is that it's imaginary. These values were great for understanding the world from a distance, for looking at a map from the comfort of your own home. But if you actually wanted to use the system to navigate, like if you were out in the middle of the ocean, you needed to be able to calculate your latitude and longitude in real time. Which was annoying.
大约是北纬37.810度，西经122.267度。这个虚构网格系统的问题在于它是虚构的。这些数值对于从远处了解世界、在舒适的家中看地图非常有用。但如果你真的想用这个系统导航，比如你在大洋中央，你需要能够实时计算你的纬度和经度。这很烦人。
Before the age of GPS, the best navigational tool available was the scumptuble. The sun, the moon, and other celestial bodies were your reference points, no matter where you were in the world. That made latitude pretty simple. It's just based on your distance north or south of the equator. Easy enough to figure out by looking at the sky. Latitude you can determine by just measuring the height of the sun or at the pole star above the horizon you see. If you can see the north star and it's 10 degrees above the horizon, you're at 10 degrees latitude. Using the sun takes a little more calculation, but it's still very doable.
在GPS时代之前，最好的导航工具是天体。太阳、月亮和其他天体是你的参考点，无论你在世界的哪个角落。这使得纬度计算变得相当简单。它只是基于你距离赤道向北或向南的距离。通过观察天空很容易算出来。你可以通过测量太阳的高度或地平线上的北极星来确定纬度。如果你能看到北极星，它在地平线上方10度，你就在北纬10度。利用太阳需要更多的计算，但仍然非常可行。
Getting longitude, on the other hand, is a completely different story. Longitude is a lot harder to find than latitude. The reason calculating longitude is so much harder is largely down to the fact that the Earth doesn't stay still. It spins. The Earth rotates west to east, which means even while the north-south values, like the poles, the equator, and lines of latitude, all still. fixed, the sides of the earth, the east-west values, are in constant motion. Calculating longitude is like trying to keep track of all the horses on a carousel. No matter how hard you try, they'll just keep spinning out of sight.
另一方面，获取经度则完全是另一回事。经度比纬度难找得多。计算经度之所以难得多，很大程度上是因为地球不会静止不动。它在旋转。地球自西向东旋转，这意味着即使南北数值（如两极、赤道和纬线）保持固定，地球的侧面（东西数值）也处于持续运动中。计算经度就像试图追踪旋转木马上的所有马匹。无论你多么努力，它们总会不断转出你的视线。
What all this means in practice is that you can't get longitude just by looking at the sky. None of those useful celestial bodies will hold still. And so for many, many years, longitude was just garbage as a real-world value. you. Sailors did manage to get around without knowing their longitude, but not very well. They were forced to make do with depressingly bad methods. One such depressingly bad method was called sailing the parallels, where ships could find one line of latitude and just stick to it until it was time to basically turn north or south off the highway. This was a really popular approach,
在实践中，这意味着你不能仅仅通过观察天空来获得经度。那些有用的天体都不会保持静止。因此，多年来，经度作为现实世界的数值简直就是垃圾。水手们确实在不知道经度的情况下设法航行，但效果并不好。他们被迫使用令人沮丧的糟糕方法。其中一种令人沮丧的糟糕方法被称为“平行航行”，即船只找到一条纬线并坚持航行，直到基本上需要转弯向北或向南离开这条“高速公路”。这是一种非常流行的方法，
enough so that everyone started sailing along the same lines. Which might have been, been a great idea if it weren't for the fact that pirates also knew these roots. And so they could just sit around doing basically no work and pick off whatever ships they wanted. Another less bad way of estimating longitude was called dead reckoning, a way of measuring speed and direction. How it worked is that you'd tie a series of knots in a rope and then throw that rope behind you in the water. How quickly the knots fed out would tell you how fast you were going. This is actually where we get knots as a unit of speed. One One knot equals one nautical mile per hour.
流行到每个人都开始沿着同样的路线航行。如果不是因为海盗也知道这些路线，这可能是一个好主意。所以他们可以坐享其成，几乎不用费力就能劫掠他们想要的任何船只。另一种估算经度的较差方法被称为“推算航法”，这是一种测量速度和方向的方法。它的工作原理是，你在绳子上打一系列结，然后把绳子扔到身后的水里。结出来的速度有多快，就能告诉你航行有多快。这实际上就是我们现在用“节”作为速度单位的由来。一节等于一海里每小时。
If you remember, nothing else. Remember that. Having a general sense of speed could tell you how far you'd gone east or west. But dead reckoning was notoriously inaccurate, especially on long journeys where even small errors could accumulate. For centuries, everyone from seamen to astronomers struggled to figure out what became known as the problem of longitude. And so much time passed without a solution that people put longitude in the same bucket as finding the philosopher's stone
如果你什么都不记得，记住这个。对速度有一个大致的了解可以告诉你向东或向西走了多远。但推算航法以不准确著称，特别是在长途航行中，即使是微小的误差也会累积。几个世纪以来，从海员到天文学家，每个人都在努力解决后来被称为“经度问题”的难题。时间流逝，却迟迟没有解决方案，以至于人们把经度问题和寻找“贤者之石”
or turning lead into gold. Basically, you'd go mad before you'd ever figure it out. The idea of discovering a way to determine Longitude at sea at that time was tantamount to attempting Mission Impossible.
或点石成金放在了同一个篮子里。基本上，你在找到答案之前就会先疯掉。在当时，发现一种在海上确定经度的方法，等同于尝试“不可能的任务”。
This is Deva Sobel, who wrote the best-selling book, Longitude. People just didn't think it could be done. It was one of those things you would talk about, like The Secret of Revenue. perpetual motion, but you didn't really expect it to happen. Still, that didn't stop the big colonial powers of Europe from trying for longitude.
这是戴娃·索贝尔，她写了畅销书《经度》。人们根本不认为这能做到。这是那种你会谈论的事情，就像“永动机”的秘密，但你并不真的指望它会发生。尽管如此，这并没有阻止欧洲的各大殖民强国为经度而努力。
There was just too much riding on a solution. The stakes were high, life and death. Having accurate coordinates at sea could mean the difference between making a swift, safe journey and, say, veering dangerously off course, hitting a rock and drowning with a guy named Cloudsley. In other words, it was just a lot safer to know where you were going. But the search for longitude wasn't only about safety. For Great Britain, it was also very clearly a matter of empire. It was really important to that vision of Britain sort of taking over the world, both commercially and literally.
解决方案的背后有太多的利益。赌注很高，关乎生死。在海上拥有准确的坐标，可能意味着顺利、安全的航行与偏离航线、撞上岩石并与那个叫肖维尔的人一起溺水身亡之间的区别。换句话说，知道你要去哪里要安全得多。但对经度的探索不仅仅是为了安全。对于大英帝国来说，这显然也是一个帝国问题。这对于英国在商业和实际上统治世界的愿景来说非常重要。
In the early 18th century, Britain had colonized parts of North America and the Caribbean, and they were actively growing the transatlantic slave trade. Having longitude would mean shorter, more predictable journeys. In other words, they'd be able to do. do more horrible things more quickly. Global powers of the time knew that there was an ill-gotten fortune to be made if your kingdom ships were the fastest, most efficient, and safest ones on the ocean. So even though everybody considered it Mission Impossible, still there was a sense of, wouldn't it be great if we could do this? So with global domination on the line,
在18世纪初，英国已经殖民了北美和加勒比地区的部分地区，并且正在积极扩大跨大西洋奴隶贸易。拥有经度意味着航程更短、更可预测。换句话说，他们将能够更快地做更多可怕的事情。当时的全球强国都知道，如果你的王国的船只是海洋上最快、最高效、最安全的，就能获得一笔不义之财。所以即使每个人都认为这是“不可能的任务”，但仍然有一种感觉：如果我们能做到这一点，那该多好？因此，随着全球统治地位的竞争，
Parliament passed the Longitude Act of 1714, which offered a fantastic monetary prize to solve this problem of finding the longitude at sea. The Longitude Act of 1714 dangled a massive prize in front of anyone who could come up with a workable solution. Parliament was trying to motivate the great scientific minds of the time for the love of God to finally figure out where the fuck they were. The rules of the act were this.
议会通过了1714年的《经度法案》，提供了一笔丰厚的奖金来解决这个海上经度问题。1714年的《经度法案》在任何能提出可行解决方案的人面前悬挂了一笔巨额奖金。议会试图激励当时伟大的科学头脑，以上帝的名义，最终弄清楚他们到底在哪儿。法案的规则是这样的。
If your idea passed muster with a board of qualified judges, you'd be sent on a trial journey to a place of known longitude. In this case, Britain's colonies in the Caribbean, then known as the West Indies, and there were different prizes depending on how close your ship got to the bullseye. If you pulled into harbor with the greatest level of accuracy, just 30 nautical miles or half a degree of longitude, you get the highest prize. The prize was 20,000 pounds. So you can imagine.
如果你的想法通过了合格评委委员会的审查，你将被派往一个已知经度的地方进行试航。在这种情况下，是英国在加勒比地区的殖民地，当时被称为西印度群岛，根据你的船只距离目标有多近，有不同的奖金。如果你以最高精度驶入港口，误差仅为30海里或半度经度，你就能获得最高奖金。奖金是2万英镑。所以你可以想象。
This was really worth extending yourself to try to win this. With the modern equivalent of around $3 million on the line, all sorts of people came out of the woodwork with wacky solutions involving, among other things, cannons, dogs, and magic powder. Most of those proposed ideas weren't given any real consideration. For one, they were stupid. But two, it was believed that if someone could find a solution to the longitude problem, that solution would probably come out of the field of astronomy. You got your latitude from the sky.
这确实值得全力以赴去争取。在相当于现代约300万美元的奖金诱惑下，各种各样的人带着古怪的解决方案冒了出来，其中包括大炮、狗和魔法粉末。大多数提议的想法都没有得到真正的考虑。首先，它们很愚蠢。但其次，人们认为如果有人能找到经度问题的解决方案，那个解决方案很可能来自天文学领域。你从天空中获得了纬度。
So why wouldn't you get your longitude? I mean, it just seemed to make sense. In the world of navigation, astronomy reigned supreme. Astronomers were men of science. And over the many, many years, they had been inching closer to a solution. But for all their high towers and stargazing, no one had managed to bring the issue of longitude within reach. That is, until an unexpected dark horse entered the race. Astronomy had an entire international network of people working on it.
所以为什么不能获得经度呢？我的意思是，这似乎很有道理。在导航世界中，天文学占据统治地位。天文学家是科学界的人。多年来，他们一直在接近解决方案。但尽管他们有高塔和观星术，却没有人能触及经度问题。直到一个意想不到的黑马进入了比赛。天文学有一个完整的国际网络在研究它。
And then this guy from Yorkshire came along with his clock. John Harrison was not an astronomer. He was a self-taught clockmaker and the son of a carpenter. He lived in an unglamorous section of England. He seems to have been entirely self-educated, and he achieved things in precision timekeeping that were highly unusual for the time. Historical records of his early life are scarce,
然后这个来自约克郡的家伙带着他的钟出现了。约翰·哈里森不是天文学家。他是一位自学成才的钟表匠，也是一位木匠的儿子。他住在英国一个不起眼的地区。他似乎完全是自学成才，他在精密计时方面取得的成就对于那个时代来说是非常罕见的。他早年生活的历史记录很少，
but we know that he was born in 1693 and generally described as a sort of single-minded, eccentric guy who was a genius when it came to clocks. Harrison was very determined to win this reward. He wanted that top reward, £20,000. This is Emily Ackermans at the Royal Observatory in Greenwich. Her title is actually the curator of time, which sounds like the name of a Doctor Who episode,
但我们知道他出生于1693年，通常被描述为一个一心一意、古怪的人，在钟表方面是个天才。哈里森非常决心赢得这个奖励。他想要那个最高奖励，2万英镑。这是格林威治皇家天文台的艾米丽·阿克曼斯。她的头衔实际上是“时间策展人”，听起来像是《神秘博士》某一集的名字，
but is actually her job. I met Emily in the observatory, surrounded by mysterious brass instruments, and all the people coming to look at them. He wasn't a member of the Clockmaker's Guild. He didn't follow a traditional apprentice path, So he did design very unique clocks. Harrison, who worked alongside his brother James, took an outsider's approach in his clockmaking.
但实际上这就是她的工作。我在天文台见到了艾米丽，周围环绕着神秘的黄铜仪器，还有所有来看它们的人。他不是钟表匠协会的成员。他没有走传统的学徒道路，所以他设计了非常独特的钟表。与兄弟詹姆斯一起工作的哈里森在钟表制作上采取了局外人的方法。
He invented new features like the gridiron pendulum and grasshopper escapement. These terms might not mean anything to you unless you study clocks, but trust me, the horology crowd is probably freaking out right now. Harrison's timekeepers were some of the best, most accurate clocks in the world, which made him particularly well suited to finally solving the longitude problem. That's because a solution to the problem of longitude at sea actually already existed, at least theoretically. What time is it in two places at once? And that will nail your position. The whole scientific community had known for a long time that it was hypothetically possible to calculate longitude using time differences. You just needed to know your own local time and the time back at your home port.
他发明了诸如“网格摆”和“蚱蜢擒纵机构”等新功能。除非你研究钟表，否则这些术语对你来说可能毫无意义，但相信我，钟表界的人现在可能正在抓狂。哈里森的计时器是世界上最好、最精确的钟表之一，这使他特别适合最终解决经度问题。这是因为解决海上经度问题的方案实际上已经存在了，至少在理论上是这样。同时在两个地方知道时间是多少？那就能确定你的位置。整个科学界早就知道，利用时间差来计算经度在假设上是可能的。你只需要知道你当地的时间和你家乡港口的时间。
The best way I've found to imagine this is to think about our time. modern concept of time zones. How many hours away something is can tell you roughly how far away that place is. So I'm in New York and Romans in California. He's three hours behind me. But Hawaii is five hours behind me, which means Hawaii is farther away than California. So time can give a pretty good estimate of distance east and west. And you can get even more precise than that. One hour equals 15 degrees of longitude. It's 1 o'clock here. It's 10 a.m. in California.
我发现想象这个问题的最好方法是思考我们现代的时区概念。某地距离你几个小时可以告诉你那个地方大致有多远。我在纽约，罗曼在加利福尼亚。他比我晚三个小时。但夏威夷比我晚五个小时，这意味着夏威夷比加利福尼亚更远。所以时间可以提供一个相当好的东西向距离估算。而且你可以比这更精确。一小时等于15度经度。这里是1点。加利福尼亚是上午10点。
Okay. So we know that's a three-hour difference, 45 degrees of longitude. And if you look on the map, I think you'll see that's about right. So if you could get your local time using the sun overhead and you knew what time it was back home, you'd know the distance between those two places.
好的。所以我们知道这是一个三小时的时差，45度经度。如果你看地图，我想你会发现这差不多是对的。所以如果你能通过头顶的太阳获得当地时间，并且知道家乡的时间，你就能知道这两个地方之间的距离。
You could calculate your longitude. This might sound like a pretty simple solution to the problem of longitude at sea. Just set a clock before leaving and take it on board your ship. But back in the 1700s, that wasn't an option. Clock design at that point was just too unreliable. They're so susceptible to inaccuracy. It's incredible. They work at all. Now I'm joking.
你可以计算出你的经度。这听起来可能是解决海上经度问题的一个相当简单的方案。出发前调好一个钟，带上船就行了。但在1700年代，那不是一个选择。当时的钟表设计太不可靠了。它们太容易出现误差了。它们能工作简直不可思议。我开玩笑的。
No, sorry. When people say it runs like clockwork, I generally think, oh, not very well then. During this era, all clocks were kind of crappy. But bring one of those crappy clocks on board a ship, and it was useless. These were mostly pendulum clocks, and you can imagine how well a pendulum clock would work on a rocking ship. There was also the issue of lubrication. The oils used in clockmaking had the tendency to get dirty and gunked up, especially in salty ocean air. And if you were traveling between warm and cold climates, the metal in your clockmaking,
不，抱歉。当人们说它像钟表一样运转时，我通常会想，哦，那运转得不怎么样。在那个时代，所有的钟表都有点烂。但把其中一个烂钟带上船，它就没用了。这些大多是摆钟，你可以想象摆钟在摇晃的船上会工作得怎么样。还有一个润滑的问题。钟表制作中使用的油容易变脏和结块，特别是在咸湿的海上空气中。如果你在温暖和寒冷的气候之间旅行，钟表里的金属，
pendulum would expand and contract with temperature, making it gain or lose time. And to actually get an exact position, your clock has to be extremely accurate. I mean, within a fraction of a fraction of a fraction of a second a day. But where others saw problems, John Harrison saw an opportunity. He thought he could solve Longitude not by looking at the stars, but by building a better clock. Harrison came up with some really ingenious and creative solutions in order to make a seaworthy clock. To get around the need for traditional clock oil, he used wood from a type of tree called lignum viti that actually exudes its own lubrication. He also solved the problem of
摆会随着温度膨胀和收缩，导致它变快或变慢。要获得精确的位置，你的钟必须极其准确。我是说，每天误差在几分之一秒之内。但当别人看到问题时，约翰·哈里森看到了机会。他认为他可以通过制造更好的钟，而不是观察星星来解决经度问题。哈里森提出了一些非常巧妙和有创意的解决方案，以制造出适航的钟。为了绕过对传统钟表油的需求，他使用了一种名为“愈疮木”的树木，它实际上会分泌自己的润滑剂。他还解决了
temperature by combining complementary metals, steel and brass, that expand at different rates and at different temperatures, which stop the metal components from changing shape. So he's already solved two of the three problems, the three main problems that are facing Portable clocks at sea. To deal with the problem of keeping a pendulum clock running on a rocking ship, Harrison made a modified pendulum with two connected bar balances that compensate for each other's motion. A clock with these balances could keep time even when tilted around. Harrison worked for five years straight to solve these three design problems. And what he ended up with was a clock known as Harrison 1, today called H1.
温度问题，通过结合互补的金属（钢和黄铜），它们在不同温度下以不同速率膨胀，这阻止了金属部件变形。所以他已经解决了海上便携式钟表面临的三个主要问题中的两个。为了解决在摇晃的船上保持摆钟运行的问题，哈里森制造了一个改进的摆，带有两个相互连接的杆式平衡器，可以补偿彼此的运动。带有这些平衡器的钟即使在倾斜时也能保持时间。哈里森花了五年时间直接解决这三个设计问题。他最终得到的是一个被称为“哈里森1号”的钟，今天称为H1。
What are we looking at right now? Wow, okay, so what are we looking at? I think it's a very strange contraption. It doesn't really look like a clock, which is why it's so unique. I have to say it looks extremely steam punk, like it could be in the Will Smith vehicle Wild Wild West. Emily showed me Harrison's C-clock, which is on display, at the Royal Observatory in Greenwich. What I looked at with Emily
我们现在在看什么？哇，好吧，我们在看什么？我觉得这是一个非常奇怪的装置。它看起来并不像一个钟，这就是它如此独特的原因。我必须说它看起来非常有蒸汽朋克风格，就像它可能出现在威尔·史密斯的电影《飙风战警》里一样。艾米丽向我展示了哈里森的C型钟，它在格林威治皇家天文台展出。我和艾米丽看的是
was actually the inner workings of the clock because sometime over the years the wooden case around it disappeared. The clock is made of gleaming brass with four small dials arranged on its face and an intricate system of tiny gears, springs, and bars
实际上是钟的内部结构，因为多年来它周围的木壳消失了。钟由闪闪发光的黄铜制成，表面排列着四个小表盘，后面是一个由微小齿轮、弹簧和杆组成的复杂系统。
behind that. It weighs a hefty 75 pounds. It's about the size of, what would you say? I always say it might just, you might get away with it as cabin, luggage. You could, yeah, maybe. Not with some airlines, but with the standard airline, you might get away carrying it. International. After Harrison finished H-1 in 1735, he got it in front of England's Premier Research Institute, the Royal Society. This was a big moment for Harrison. A good review
它重达75磅。它大约有多大？你会怎么说？我总是说它可能，你也许可以把它当作随身行李带上飞机。你可以，是的，也许吧。不是在某些航空公司，但在标准航空公司，你也许可以带着它。国际航班。哈里森在1735年完成H1后，把它带到了英国首屈一指的研究机构——皇家学会面前。这对哈里森来说是一个重要的时刻。一个好的评价
from the society might put his invention in front of the judges of the Longitude Act. While the Society was impressed with Harrison's clock, they were also pretty hesitant to trust that his idea would work. Because why would they? You know, he's just a guy. He's doing all this in his home. At this point, Harrison was just a clockmaker with no scientific background. So having some skepticism about the whole thing, the society decided to give H1 a preliminary test, a test test, not to the West Indies, but to Lisbon. They agreed to put it on a boat, but they just sent it to Portugal, so not making the huge transatlantic voyage. Harrison apparently got extremely seasick on the trip,
来自学会可能会把他的发明推到《经度法案》的评委面前。虽然学会对哈里森的钟印象深刻，但他们也相当犹豫是否要相信他的想法会奏效。因为他们为什么要相信呢？你知道，他只是个普通人。他是在家里做这一切的。此时，哈里森只是一个没有科学背景的钟表匠。因此，对整件事持怀疑态度，学会决定给H1进行初步测试，一个测试性的测试，不是去西印度群岛，而是去里斯本。他们同意把它放在船上，但只是把它送到葡萄牙，所以没有进行巨大的跨大西洋航行。哈里森显然在旅途中晕船非常严重，
like seasick enough that we are still talking about it 290 years later, but H1 performed marvelously. In fact, when the HMS Orford was on its way back to Britain, the ship's sailing master had them on course to pass a landmark just south of Dartmouth. But Harrison, using H1, sounded the alarm. He was able to pinpoint the ship's location as 60 miles off course to the west.
严重到我们290年后还在谈论它，但H1的表现非常出色。事实上，当“奥福德号”（HMS Orford）在返回英国的途中时，船上的航海长让他们保持航向，经过达特茅斯以南的一个地标。但哈里森利用H1拉响了警报。他能够将船的位置精确定位在向西偏离航线60英里处。
And then it turned out that he was right. And you can imagine how that affected the captain, everybody on the crew. Harrison's timekeeper was able to correct the ship's longitude. Wow, that was a magic trick. That was just how did you do that? And how he had done it was with that clock. And the whole crew of the ship he was on,
结果证明他是对的。你可以想象这对船长和船上所有船员的影响。哈里森的计时器能够纠正船只的经度。哇，那是一个魔术。那简直是“你是怎么做到的？”而他是用那个钟做到的。他所在的船上的全体船员，
they're all ready to stand up for him. He's not a crank. It's not what everybody was expecting, but he's not a crank. He's got something. So with the blessing of the Royal Society, all eight members of the official Board of Longitude assembled to hear about the successful Portugal trial and to judge Harrison's C-clock. And Harrison is there with his clock. And what does he do?
他们都准备为他站台。他不是个疯子。这不是每个人所期望的，但他不是个疯子。他确实有东西。因此，在皇家学会的祝福下，官方经度委员会的所有八名成员聚集在一起，听取了葡萄牙试航成功的报告，并评估哈里森的C型钟。哈里森带着他的钟在那里。他做了什么？
He says, I don't think it's really good enough yet. He didn't want that big trial? No, not yet. Harrison could have asked for his H1C clock to go on a trial to the West Indies, and it's likely the board would have given it to him. He could have tried for the prize, but he didn't do that. What he did do was solidify his place as the absolute worst venture capitalist in the history of the world. Harrison was so obsessed with getting his invention precisely, exactly, perfectly right, that he showed up in a room full of people practically begging to give him a big pile of money,
他说，我觉得它还不够好。他不想进行那次大试航？不，还没到时候。哈里森本可以要求他的H1 C型钟去西印度群岛进行试航，委员会很可能会同意。他本可以尝试争取奖金，但他没有这样做。他所做的是巩固了他作为世界历史上最糟糕的风险投资家的地位。哈里森太痴迷于让他的发明精确、准确、完美，以至于他出现在一屋子几乎乞求给他一大笔钱的人面前，
and he pointed out the problems with his own design. He was apparently the only person in the room to say anything negative about his work. And so, like the terrible entrepreneur he was, Harrison went back to the drawing board. So H1, maybe we'd call that beta, it proves the principle. A clock on a boat will work. It will tell you the time better than the ship's navigator. That's what you need. What followed were over 20 years of working and reworking and reworking and reworking designs for various Harrison C clocks.
他却指出了自己设计的问题。他显然是房间里唯一一个对自己的作品说负面话的人。所以，就像他那个糟糕的企业家一样，哈里森回到了绘图板前。所以H1，也许我们称之为测试版，它证明了原理。船上的钟会工作。它会比船上的领航员更好地告诉你时间。这就是你所需要的。接下来是20多年来对各种哈里森C型钟设计的不断改进、重做、再重做。
All this time, John Harrison had been tinkering and tinkering, making prototypes with changes big and small to the same basic formula as H-1. But then, in the mid-1750s, Harrison just happened to get a new pocket watch. The watch was for his personal use made by another clockmaker. At the time, watches were extremely unreliable, even more so than regular clocks, which, as we've established, were very crappy. You know, a gentleman might have a pocket watch, but it was just for vanity. It didn't really keep good time.
一直以来，约翰·哈里森都在修修补补，用与H1相同的基本公式制作原型，进行大大小小的改动。但后来，在1750年代中期，哈里森碰巧得到了一块新的怀表。这块表是他个人使用的，由另一位钟表匠制作。当时，手表极其不可靠，甚至比普通的钟表更不可靠，正如我们已经确定的，那些钟表非常烂。你知道，绅士可能会有一块怀表，但那只是为了虚荣。它并没有真正保持准确的时间。
But this watch, which used some of Harrison's improvements, was extremely accurate. Harrison looked down at his shiny new pocket watch and he realized that the key to a perfect sea clock was that he needed to think smaller. His other clocks were massive. And wouldn't it be so much better to have something small and practical that a captain out at sea could keep on him at all times and carry in his hand? It took him four years to complete his C-watch, H-4. H4 was 5 inches in diameter and it weighed just 3 pounds. So compared to the carry-on luggage of H-1, it could fit in a free personal item. Except on Spirit Airlines, then it would probably cost 50 bucks.
但这块使用了哈里森的一些改进的手表非常准确。哈里森看着他闪亮的新怀表，意识到完美海上钟表的关键在于他需要往小处想。他的其他钟表太巨大了。如果能有一些小巧实用的东西，让海上的船长可以随时带在身上，拿在手里，那不是更好吗？他花了四年时间完成了他的C型表，H4。H4直径5英寸，重量仅3磅。所以与H1的随身行李相比，它可以装进一个免费的个人物品里。除了在精神航空（Spirit Airlines），那样可能要花50块钱。
Looking at H4 in the Royal Observatory, I was struck by just how different it looks from any of Harrison's earlier C-clocks. If the other ones look pretty steampunk, this looks just like so ornate and beautiful and delicate. Like, how would you describe that? There's all this like curving filigree, these blue iridescent dots. There's like rubies and diamonds in there, right? Yes, yes. So diamond palettes, we're still not entirely sure how we made them. I was going to say, are the, are the gems just gratuitous? Are they flare? Do they have a purpose? They have a purpose, they do, yes. And it's all anti-friction or minimizing friction. When Harrison finished H-4, he didn't do what he'd done with his other inventions. He didn't insist that this one wasn't right,
在皇家天文台看着H4，我被它与哈里森早期任何C型钟截然不同的外观所震撼。如果其他的看起来很蒸汽朋克，这个看起来非常华丽、美丽且精致。就像，你会怎么描述它？有所有这些弯曲的细丝，这些蓝色的虹彩点。里面有红宝石和钻石，对吧？是的，是的。所以钻石擒纵叉，我们仍然不完全确定他是怎么制作它们的。我正想说，这些宝石只是多余的吗？它们是装饰吗？它们有用途吗？它们有用途，确实有，是的。而且都是为了抗摩擦或最小化摩擦。当哈里森完成H4时，他没有像对待其他发明那样做。他没有坚持说这个还不完美，
or ask for more time. He was finally, finally ready to have his work tested and collect the Longitude Prize. Perfectionist, do you think? Yeah. So that's what was one of the most interesting things to me, that when he made H-4, he knew he'd really done it. And he had this wonderful saying, I think I remember it. I think it is fair to say that there is no other mechanical thing that is as beautiful or as curious in texture as this my watch or timekeeper for the longitude. Satisfied finally with his invention, Harrison presented H4 to the Board of Longitude. The board agreed to send the timepiece on its official trial to Jamaica, with that big,
或者要求更多时间。他终于，终于准备好让他的作品接受测试并领取经度奖了。完美主义者，你觉得呢？是的。所以这是我最感兴趣的事情之一，当他制作H4时，他知道他真的做到了。他有一句很棒的话，我想我记得。我认为可以公平地说，没有其他机械装置像我这块用于经度的手表或计时器那样，在质地上如此美丽或奇妙。终于对他的发明感到满意，哈里森将H4提交给了经度委员会。委员会同意将这块计时器送往牙买加进行官方试航，那一大笔
fat pile of quid resting on the results. To take top prize, Harrison would need to bring H4 by C to Jamaica and then on arrival take longitude calculations. If the difference between Harrison's number and the real longitude of Jamaica was within 30 nautical miles or half a degree of longitude, he would at long last take home the prize. Harrison himself was getting up in age. He was almost 70. So when classic dad fashion. He made his kid do it. In 1761, Harrison's son William traveled with H4 all the way across the Atlantic Ocean on a two-month journey through icy cold, humid heat, and rolling seas.
英镑奖金就取决于结果。要获得最高奖金，哈里森需要通过海路将H4带到牙买加，然后在抵达时进行经度计算。如果哈里森的数字与牙买加的真实经度之间的差异在30海里或半度经度之内，他最终将把奖金带回家。哈里森本人年纪大了。他快70岁了。所以按照经典的父亲作风，他让他儿子去做了。1761年，哈里森的儿子威廉带着H4，在冰冷、潮湿、炎热和波涛汹涌的海面上，历经两个月的航行，横跨大西洋。
He collected his data, which was accurate to about a single nautical mile, way closer than the 30-mile cutoff. But when William returned home expecting to claim the reward, the Board of Longitude said that, sorry, actually, the trial was void. partly because they thought the result might be a fluke, and partly because they didn't actually know the Longitude of Jamaica. They sent him to Jamaica even though they weren't sure where Jamaica was. This was insane behavior, a huge waste of time.
他收集了数据，精度达到大约一海里，远比30海里的截止线要近。但当威廉回到家期待领取奖励时，经度委员会却说，抱歉，实际上，试航无效。部分原因是他们认为结果可能是侥幸，部分原因是他们实际上不知道牙买加的经度。他们派他去牙买加，尽管他们不确定牙买加在哪里。这简直是疯狂的行为，极大地浪费时间。
Obviously, the Harrisons were exasperated. From this point on, the Board of Longitude kept holding the prize just out of reach. In 1764, Harrison got a new trial, this time. to Barbados. He aces it again, but the board equivocates. They kept moving the goalpost. Harrison may have finally perfected his watch, but his timing was horrible. It took him so long that by this point, most of his friends and allies on the board had retired or just straight up died. And the new commissioners of Longitude were unfortunately the worst thing an eccentric creative type could encounter.
显然，哈里森一家被激怒了。从这一点开始，经度委员会一直把奖金悬在够不着的地方。1764年，哈里森获得了新的试航机会，这次是去巴巴多斯。他再次表现出色，但委员会却含糊其辞。他们不断移动目标。哈里森可能终于完善了他的手表，但他的时机太糟糕了。他花了太长时间，以至于到这个时候，他在委员会中的大多数朋友和盟友都已经退休或直接去世了。而新的经度专员不幸地是一个古怪的创意型人才所能遇到的最糟糕的事情。
They were pragmatists. Here's Alexi Baker again. The big problem, the reason he was conflicting with the commissioners, is they thought it wouldn't help the nation if they couldn't also replicate his watches. The Board of Longitude was looking at Harrison and saying, this is a guy who's over 70 years old. He'd taken decades to build one watch, and they weren't even sure he could make a second one,
他们是实用主义者。这是亚历克西·贝克。最大的问题，他与专员们发生冲突的原因是，他们认为如果他们不能复制他的手表，这对国家就没有帮助。经度委员会看着哈里森说，这是一个70多岁的人。他花了数十年才造出一块手表，他们甚至不确定他是否能造出第二块，
let alone put them in the hands of every captain trying to make their way across the open seas. So they could be amazing one-offs, but would it be affordable and possible for other people because he was getting on an age for other people to make a lot more watches? Not to mention that Harrison had in fact been so slow that the astronomers who had taken centuries to find a solution to longitude had basically caught up. They actually had found an okay way of calculating longitude
更不用说把它们交到每一个试图横跨公海的船长手中了。所以它们可能是了不起的孤品，但考虑到他年纪大了，其他人能否负担得起并有可能制造出更多手表？更不用说哈里森实际上太慢了，以至于花了几个世纪才找到经度解决方案的天文学家们基本上已经赶上了。他们实际上找到了一种计算经度的不错方法，
called the lunar distance method. And it worked. As long as you had a highly educated person on board, a set of tables and several hours of calculation time to spare. The Board of Longitude kept setting up new hoops for Harrison to jump through. Harrison lost his patience, and he and his son Williams started publishing attacks against the board. I honestly, even though it's silly to feel sorry for people in the 1700s, I feel sorry for both the Harrisons and the commissioners because they both had very valid points.
称为“月距法”。而且它奏效了。只要你船上有受过高等教育的人、一套表格和几个小时的计算时间。经度委员会不断为哈里森设置新的障碍。哈里森失去了耐心，他和儿子威廉开始发表攻击委员会的文章。老实说，尽管为1700年代的人感到难过很傻，但我既为哈里森一家感到难过，也为专员们感到难过，因为他们都有非常正当的理由。
And also, you can definitely understand John Harrison was old by the standards of the time. He was tired. He had more medical ailments. He wanted this solved and to get his reward, you know. He just wants to be done with this clock. Yes, it had been his whole life since 1730s. In the end, Harrison and his son decided to pull the boldest, most daring card they had up their sleeve. They tattled. William Harrison personally appealed to famous clock enthusiast and America loser King George III to step in. There were many reasons to cry.
而且，你绝对可以理解约翰·哈里森在那个时代已经老了。他累了。他有更多的疾病。他想解决这个问题并获得奖励，你知道。他只是想完成这个钟。是的，自1730年代以来，这就是他的全部生活。最后，哈里森和他的儿子决定打出他们手中最大胆、最冒险的一张牌。他们告状了。威廉·哈里森亲自向著名的钟表爱好者和美国失败者乔治三世国王求助。有很多理由哭泣。
This is unfair. And the king agreed that it was unfair and tested the fifth one in his private observatory and was convinced that Harrison had been very, very badly treated. Speaking to William at Windsor Castle, the king supposedly said that they had been cruelly treated and exclaimed, by God, Harrison, I will see you write it. In 1772, King George tested a copy of H4 called, you guessed it, H5, and was thoroughly impressed by its accuracy. At the instruction of the king, Parliament awarded John Harrison the rest of the money he was owed as a thank you for his decades of work. Crucially, though, the money was only a thank you. It was not the Longitude Prize, which the board maintained he had not earned. Of course, he felt hard done by. he was probably never fully happy even after he got that recognition.
这不公平。国王也认为这不公平，他在自己的私人天文台测试了第五台钟表，并确信哈里森受到了非常、非常糟糕的对待。据说国王在温莎城堡对威廉说，他们受到了残酷的对待，并惊呼道：看在上帝的份上，哈里森，我会看着你把它写出来。1772年，乔治国王测试了H4的一个复制品，也就是你猜到的H5，并对其精确度留下了深刻印象。在国王的指示下，议会授予约翰·哈里森他应得的剩余款项，作为对他几十年来工作的感谢。但关键在于，这笔钱仅仅是一种感谢。它并不是经度奖，委员会坚持认为他没有赢得该奖项。当然，他感到自己受到了不公正的对待。即使在获得那种认可之后，他可能也从未完全快乐过。
Harrison died in 1776 just a few years later. And it did take a minute, or more like a few decades, for manufacturers to even come close to replicating the near perfection of H4. But by the early 19th century, variations of Harrison's Sea Watch were everywhere. These instruments became generically known as marine chronometers. Unfortunately, the marine chronometer did exactly. what Parliament had hoped when they first set up the Longitude Act over a century earlier. It threw gasoline on the fire of British imperialism.
哈里森在几年后的1776年去世了。制造商确实花了一段时间，或者更确切地说是几十年，才接近复制出H4近乎完美的程度。但到了19世纪初，哈里森“海上钟表”的变体随处可见。这些仪器被统称为航海天文钟。不幸的是，航海天文钟完全实现了议会在一个多世纪前首次设立《经度法案》时所希望的目标。它为大英帝国的扩张火上浇油。
The Royal Navy made marine chronometers standard issue, and captains of merchant vessels, like those sailing with the British East India Company, got their own chronometers too. Here's Deva Sobel again. Once they really knew where they were going and where they were, that was a powerful aid to many things they did. for good and ill. By the time marine chronometers were widespread, Britain had abolished slavery and left the transatlantic slave trade.
英国皇家海军将航海天文钟作为标准配置，像英国东印度公司船只那样的商船船长们也拥有了自己的天文钟。再次请出德瓦·索贝尔。一旦他们真正知道自己要去哪里以及身处何地，这对他们所做的许多事情都是一种强大的辅助，无论好坏。到航海天文钟普及之时，英国已经废除了奴隶制并退出了跨大西洋奴隶贸易。
But it was colonizing faster than ever, spreading beyond North America and the Caribbean and into Africa, Asia, and the Pacific. And since any tool that helped navigation helped imperialism, the marine chronometer was a key part of the evil doings. In the end, the marine chronometer ended up being just one tool in a time. toolbox full of tools that the British used for world domination. But actually, one of the chronometer's most lasting impacts came indirectly from its role in mapmaking. James Cook used his Harrison-style chronometer on his second voyage. He took it south of the Antarctic Circle, where he surveyed parts of the world never before represented on European maps. And the logbooks on a ship, the HMS resolution, called the chronometer, our trusty friend, the watch.
但它的殖民速度比以往任何时候都快，从北美和加勒比地区扩展到非洲、亚洲和太平洋地区。由于任何有助于导航的工具都有助于帝国主义，航海天文钟成为了这些邪恶行径的关键部分。最终，航海天文钟只是英国用于统治世界的工具箱中的一个工具。但实际上，天文钟最持久的影响之一间接来自于它在制图方面的作用。詹姆斯·库克在第二次航行中使用了他的哈里森式天文钟。他把它带到了南极圈以南，在那里他勘测了欧洲地图上从未出现过的世界部分地区。而“决心号”上的航海日志称这台天文钟为“我们值得信赖的朋友，那块表”。
In 1831, the surveying vessel, the HMS Beagle, carried Charles Darwin to the Galapagos. It also carried 22 marine chronometers. You know, just in case. Bare minimum, you'd have a few because you would use them all and then compare them. You want to have backup. You always want to have backup. The widespread use of marine chronometers meant that by the late 19th century, most Western trading vessels were using British maritime charts.
1831年，勘测船“小猎犬号”载着查尔斯·达尔文前往加拉帕戈斯群岛。它还携带了22台航海天文钟。你知道的，以防万一。最起码，你会带上几台，因为你会使用它们并进行比较。你需要备份。你总是需要备份。航海天文钟的广泛使用意味着到19世纪末，大多数西方商船都在使用英国的海图。
So when a global conference was held to pick one standard line of zero degrees longitude for the international community, the choice was obvious. Greenwich, England was chosen as Longitude Zero, the Prime Meridian. And with that, England, with the help of John Harrison, became, cartographically speaking, the center of the world. I wonder how having longitude changed navigation. People stopped dying so much. Back on the Buccaneer with Todd, as he was steering us through jagged rocks and hundreds of shipwrecks, I didn't take for granted that I could just look at the dashboard and get information that a few hundred years ago would have seemed like a miracle.
因此，当举行全球会议为国际社会选择一条零度经度的标准线时，选择显而易见。英国格林威治被选为零度经度，即本初子午线。至此，在约翰·哈里森的帮助下，英国在制图学上成为了世界的中心。我想知道经度是如何改变航海的。人们不再那么容易死亡了。回到托德的“海盗号”上，当他引导我们穿过锯齿状的岩石和数百处沉船时，我并没有认为我可以随意查看仪表盘并获得几百年前看起来像奇迹一样的信息是理所当然的。
You're looking at the screen right now. What is that? That's a GPS that shows you where all the rocks are and where all the wrecks are. I put them on there. And what's our longitude right now? Our longitude. We're North 4953-3-340, Weth006213-368. Good to know. Good.
你现在正在看屏幕。那是什么？那是GPS，它显示了所有的岩石和沉船在哪里。我把它们标在上面了。我们现在的经度是多少？我们的经度。我们是北纬49度53分3.340秒，西经006度21分3.368秒。很高兴知道。很好。
After the break, we talk about a method for long-distance sea travel that existed millennia before Europeans cracked longitude. So I'm back with Kelly Prime. I hear you have some more for me. I do. So as I was reporting this story, one element kept coming up for me, which is that the story we're telling about longitude and the longitude problem and the act is a very Eurocentric one. Like, yeah, I can't, like, actually picture any of these characters not wearing powdered blades, you know? Totally. That's totally true. And since the problem of finding longitude was essentially the problem of figuring out a way to safely travel long distances at sea, I was really curious about how other cultures managed to do that. And the most extraordinary version that I found comes from the Pacific Islands, where navigators have been traveling between these, like, teen,
休息之后，我们将讨论一种在欧洲人破解经度问题前几千年就存在的远距离海上航行方法。我又和凯利·普莱姆在一起了。我听说你还有更多东西要告诉我。是的。所以当我在报道这个故事时，有一个元素一直出现在我脑海中，那就是我们讲述的关于经度、经度问题和法案的故事是非常以欧洲为中心的。就像，是的，我无法想象这些角色中任何一个不戴着粉末假发的样子，你知道吗？完全正确。这完全是真的。由于寻找经度的问题本质上是寻找一种安全进行远距离海上航行的方法，我真的很好奇其他文化是如何做到这一点的。我发现的最非凡的版本来自太平洋岛屿，那里的航海家们几千年来一直在这些，比如，十几，
tiny islands separated by thousands of miles of ocean for millennia, like centuries and centuries before the Longitude Act. So to find out more, I called up probably like one of the coolest people I've ever met. My name is Lehuahua Kamalu, and I am a captain and navigator and sometimes crew member of traditional Polynesian voyaging canoes. Lehuahua Kamalu is based in Honolulu and works on the canoes, Hokulea and Hiki Analia. And she's one of the few people on Earth using traditional skills to navigate vast distances at sea, which means no GPS and definitely no marine chronometer. There is no timepiece involved in the wayfinding in this way.
被数千英里海洋隔开的小岛之间航行，比《经度法案》早了几个世纪。为了了解更多，我给可能是我见过最酷的人之一打了电话。我的名字是莱胡阿·卡马鲁，我是一名传统波利尼西亚航海独木舟的船长、导航员，有时也是船员。莱胡阿·卡马鲁常驻檀香山，在“霍库雷亚号”和“希基·阿纳利亚号”独木舟上工作。她是地球上少数几个利用传统技能在海上进行远距离航行的人之一，这意味着没有GPS，也绝对没有航海天文钟。这种寻路方式不涉及任何计时器。
And so I'll probably call it non-instrument navigation. That's probably the simplest way to describe it. I mean, to me, there's nothing simple about navigating thousands of miles between tiny islands in the middle of the Pacific Ocean. So how does she do it? Yeah, well, I'll say first that a lot of the original techniques for this kind of navigation have been lost over the years because of colonization. But Lehuah and her colleagues use their own interpretation of the methods that Pacific
所以我可能会称之为非仪器导航。这可能是描述它最简单的方法。我的意思是，对我来说，在太平洋中部的小岛之间航行数千英里一点也不简单。那么她是怎么做到的呢？是的，首先我要说，这种导航的许多原始技术由于殖民化而在多年中失传了。但莱胡阿和她的同事们使用了他们自己对太平洋岛民所使用方法的诠释，
Islanders used thousands of years ago. Back then, navigators in the Pacific Islands had a lot of the same challenges as Europeans. Basically, there's only so much information you can easily get from the sun and the stars. And so it kind of makes sense that the starting point for Polynesian wayfinding is actually pretty similar to the European concept of dead reckoning. You need to constantly watch, like, are we making good progress? Are we still doing the same speed? Are we a little slower? Are we a little faster? You know, are these conditions, the standard conditions that we expect? Or are we experiencing something that is out of the norm? And how do we account for that? Ultimately, though, this approach isn't enough. LaHua says it gets you in the right direction. But the longer the journey, the more errors can add up. So you need a way to get more confident in where you are and where you're going at sea.
那些方法是几千年前使用的。那时，太平洋岛屿的航海家们面临着与欧洲人相同的许多挑战。基本上，你能从太阳和星星中轻松获得的信息是有限的。所以波利尼西亚寻路的起点实际上与欧洲的推测航法概念非常相似，这很有道理。你需要不断观察，比如，我们进展顺利吗？我们还在保持同样的速度吗？我们是慢了一点，还是快了一点？你知道，这些条件是我们预期的标准条件吗？还是我们正在经历一些不寻常的事情？我们该如何解释这一点？然而，最终这种方法是不够的。莱胡阿说它能让你朝着正确的方向前进。但旅程越长，累积的误差就越多。所以你需要一种方法来更确定你在海上的位置以及你要去的地方。
And so instead of using something like latitude and longitude, Polynesian wayfinders take a more holistic approach. Let's just imagine the world, not so much with an imaginary grid on it, and rather just see it in the natural way that it is. and I think what it forces you to do is to allow nature to tell you where you are and not you to tell nature where you are. And what does that mean exactly, letting nature tell you where you are? Okay, so what Lahua told me is that even when you're out at sea,
因此，波利尼西亚寻路者没有使用纬度和经度之类的东西，而是采取了一种更全面的方法。让我们想象一下这个世界，不是用一个虚构的网格覆盖它，而是以它原本的自然方式来看待它。我认为它强迫你做的是让大自然告诉你你在哪里，而不是你告诉大自然你在哪里。那么，让大自然告诉你你在哪里到底是什么意思？好的，莱胡阿告诉我的意思是，即使你在海上，
way out of sight of land, that doesn't mean you don't have information. In fact, your natural surroundings provide a lot of data that can be used to figure out where you are and where you're going? It's not that you are traveling from point A to point B with absolutely nothing in the middle. There's an ocean that is pointing you in the right direction. There are wave patterns. There are animals. There are wind directions.
远离陆地，这并不意味着你没有信息。事实上，你的自然环境提供了大量的数据，可以用来弄清楚你在哪里以及你要去哪里。并不是说你从A点到B点，中间什么都没有。有一片海洋在指引你朝着正确的方向前进。有波浪模式。有动物。有风向。
There are clouds in the sky. There is a never-ending display of celestial bodies of planets and stars and the sun and the moon and all these features that are continuously telling you what direction you're going in if you're paying attention. So I think I understand that there are these natural features in the environment that you can use to navigate. But how does she apply what she's seeing and hearing? Like how does she make practical sense of it all in terms of setting a specific course for her canoe? Great question. And one example that Lahua gave me was birds, specifically land. birds. So you might be trying to locate one little island in the Pacific and you could be out of
天空中还有云。还有永无止境的天体展示，行星、恒星、太阳、月亮，所有这些特征如果你留心的话，都在不断地告诉你你正朝着什么方向前进。所以我认为我明白了，环境中有这些自然特征可以用来导航。但她是如何应用她所看到和听到的呢？比如，在为她的独木舟设定特定航线方面，她是如何将这一切转化为实际意义的？好问题。莱胡阿给我的一个例子是鸟类，特别是陆地鸟类。所以你可能正试图在太平洋中定位一个小岛，你可能在
sight of land. But if you look up and see a land bird flying overhead, like a type of bird that you know doesn't like to go very far from home, that tells you something. And it means you're in the radius of some kind of land. And suddenly you see that island, if you imagine the island, not just as the land above the water, but also the animals and the birds that live on. that island. They are part of that island as well. So the island becomes much bigger. And soon, you start to say, well, also the waves around that island are affected much further out. So in a way, those waves are also part of that island. And suddenly the island is actually just this massive target. And if you start to see all the signs that say, I'm an island, it's not just land, right? You
看不见陆地的地方。但如果你抬头看到一只陆地鸟飞过头顶，比如一种你知道不喜欢离家太远的鸟，那就会告诉你一些事情。这意味着你在某种陆地的半径范围内。突然间你看到了那个岛，如果你把岛屿想象成不仅仅是水面上的陆地，还有生活在那个岛上的动物和鸟类。它们也是那个岛的一部分。所以岛屿变得大得多了。很快，你开始说，嗯，那个岛周围的波浪也受到了更远范围的影响。所以从某种意义上说，这些波浪也是那个岛的一部分。突然间，这个岛实际上只是一个巨大的目标。如果你开始看到所有显示“我是一个岛屿”的迹象，那不仅仅是陆地，对吧？你
don't just have to see a rock or a tree to know an island is there. And I think that suddenly makes you realize how going after one island that might only be 10 miles, you know, around becomes going after an island that's 200 or 300 miles around. And you're trying to expand your perspective to see the ways that you can see an island without actually just seeing the island itself. I love this so much. That's so cool. It really is. So, okay. So, You know, she can see a 10-mile island as a 300-mile island. That's amazing. And but I do wonder, like, as, you know, you are relying on the natural world to be your sort of navigational guide that climate changes and changes in the environment, you know, like could change the way she should read them.
不必非要看到岩石或树木才知道岛屿在那里。我认为这突然让你意识到，追寻一个可能只有10英里左右的岛屿，变成了追寻一个200或300英里左右的岛屿。你试图扩展你的视角，去观察那些即使不直接看到岛屿本身也能发现它的方式。我太喜欢这个了。这太酷了。确实如此。所以，好的。你知道，她能把一个10英里的岛屿看作一个300英里的岛屿。这太神奇了。但我确实想知道，当你依赖自然世界作为你的导航指南时，气候变化和环境变化，你知道，是否会改变她解读它们的方式。
Did she talk about that? She did because, you know, like you're saying, with the entire basis of your navigation system is the natural world, even. even like the tiniest changes to one ocean current or one species of bird can make a massive difference. I think it's really something I think about a lot today is just how much life in the ocean is no longer there. When you think about how critical just that one bird is, you start to connect all of the sensitivities of the system. And it all has to work for it to work for you. So you become quite attentive to what supports the system that allows the navigation, and that is a healthy ecosystem. I mean, you think about one species of bird that lives on an island, and if something happened to that one species, she would know the difference.
她谈到过这一点吗？她谈到了，因为正如你所说，你的导航系统的整个基础是自然世界，即使是洋流或某种鸟类最微小的变化也会产生巨大的影响。我认为这确实是我今天经常思考的事情，那就是海洋中还有多少生命已经不复存在了。当你想到仅仅那一只鸟是多么关键时，你就会开始连接系统中所有的敏感性。为了让你成功，这一切都必须协同工作。所以你变得非常关注支持导航系统的因素，那就是一个健康的生态系统。我的意思是，你想到生活在岛上的一种鸟类，如果那种鸟类发生了什么事，她会知道其中的区别。
Like, it would affect her navigation potentially. It's just sort of an amazing concept to sort of think about. Yeah, she actually talked about feral cat colonies on. islands and how when there's feral cat colonies, those cats will kill the birds. And when you don't have the birds, you don't have the birds at sea. So it's like even one tiny, tiny thing throws off how you can find where you are in the ocean. It's kind of crazy. It's crazy. It's so interesting. So I also want to mention that Lahua and her colleagues at the Polynesian Voyaging Society are currently doing this big project to circumnavigate the Pacific on traditional voyaging canoes.
就像，这可能会影响她的导航。这真是一个令人惊叹的概念。是的，她实际上谈到了岛上的野猫群，以及当有野猫群时，那些猫会杀死鸟类。当你没有鸟类时，你在海上就没有鸟类了。所以即使是一件非常非常微小的事情也会打乱你在海洋中定位的方式。这有点疯狂。这很疯狂。太有趣了。所以我也想提一下，莱胡阿和她在波利尼西亚航海协会的同事们目前正在进行一个大型项目，用传统的航海独木舟环绕太平洋航行。
It's a 43,000 nautical mile voyage, and Lehua is one of 400 crew members taking turns doing different legs of this journey. And the day I talked to Lehua, she was getting ready. It was literally the day before. She was getting ready to fly out to start a 2,000 mile journey from the Cook Islands to New Zealand. And the whole voyage should take about four years. I think they started in 2023. And she was getting on the phone to talk to you the day. before she was leaving on this four-year journey?
这是一次43,000海里的航行，莱胡阿是轮流进行这段旅程不同航段的400名船员之一。我和莱胡阿交谈的那天，她正在准备。真的是前一天。她正准备飞往那里，开始从库克群岛到新西兰的2,000英里旅程。整个航行应该需要大约四年。我想他们是在2023年开始的。她在离开进行这次四年旅程的前一天给你打电话交谈？
Yeah, she was like, I should really, really pack. I should really pack. But this wasn't, you know, she's doing one leg of the journey. She was going to do one leg. Okay, that sounds better. Okay, it sounds good. Yeah, so the whole voyage should take four years. And the goal is to connect communities in the Pacific and also to spread awareness about
是的，她说，我真的真的应该打包了。我真的应该打包。但这并不是，你知道，她只是在进行旅程的一个航段。她要完成一个航段。好的，那听起来好多了。好的，听起来不错。是的，所以整个航行应该需要四年。目标是连接太平洋地区的社区，并传播关于
the importance of protecting indigenous knowledge and ocean ecosystems. Yeah, yeah. So is there a way to track where she is in the world? There is, yeah. So you can go to the Polynesian Voyaging Society website, and there's a map that lets you track the journey, the various legs of the journey. That is so cool. I'm so glad we talked about this. This is so much fun. Thanks, Roman. It's been really fun. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Kelly Prime and edited by Vivian Lay, mixed by Brendan Burns. Music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. Special thanks this week to Richard Dunn, Rebecca Higgott, Trevor Newman, and Terry High.
保护土著知识和海洋生态系统重要性的意识。是的，是的。那么有什么方法可以追踪她在世界上的位置吗？有的，是的。你可以访问波利尼西亚航海协会的网站，上面有一张地图，可以让你追踪旅程，以及旅程的各个航段。这太酷了。我很高兴我们谈论了这个。这太有趣了。谢谢你，罗曼。这真的很有趣。本周的《99%隐形》由凯利·普莱姆报道，薇薇安·莱编辑，布伦丹·伯恩斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里尔和乔治·兰福德创作。事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙完成。本周特别感谢理查德·邓恩、丽贝卡·希戈特、特雷弗·纽曼和特里·海。
I mean. Kathy 2 is our executive producer. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Delany Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Barubei, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Martin Gonzalez, Christopher Johnson, Lashma Don, Joe Rosenberg, Jacob Medina Gleason, Tallinn, and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. in beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI and 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我的意思是。凯西·2是我们的执行制片人。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。德莱尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、马丁·冈萨雷斯、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什玛·唐、乔·罗森伯格、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、塔林和雷恩·斯特拉德利，以及我，罗曼·马斯。《99%隐形》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们新的Discord服务器。那里有一个链接，以及《99PI》的每一集往期节目，网址是99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。